Nhanh của u cua nâng em 5-2 đã đặt thoả thuận chào đổi 8-10 mũi bún tuyên trong khuôn khu vòng hòa đàn và bên giòn Mỹ bảo chờ tại Abu Dabi,
đánh giấu cuộc chào đổi đủ tiền dựa 2-6 năm tháng giả đoàn.
Nャ, phà yên, viên Steve Scott cho biết, thoả thuận là kết quả triết từ các cuộc đàn phán hả các bên đều muta là hiệu quả và thực chất.
Chừng đoàn đàn phán u cua nâ如 stang, mero sang nha đoàn các cuộc thảo lận tập chung và những bước đi của thế.
Nông thời cho biết quả chính đàn phán sẽ tiếp tục trong các ngày tới.
Tuy nhiên, những bất đồng có loại và tổn tài, đã viên lạy lạy lâu của mắt sơ và bột kia giúp quân khỏi của nỗi nhất.
Chân cả với quên khip sốt, nhằm điện hạm nhanh dạp huy dia.
Sống sông với tiến truyền ngoại giao.
Cô nội u cua nâng của ngày thung bào đã tiến hành các đột tấn công trong tháng mốt.
Nhanh bảo hà tăng và bải thử tên lửa các sửa tìm dạ của nha.
Nơi được sử dụng để chuẩn bị phòng tế lợ đả đạo tâm chung và liên lục đia.
Theo kia, một số nhà trí ở vật công trình gửi thật tại đây bị hương hải bột nha phải sơ tán nhanh sơ.
Bột quên nha cho biết đã sử dụng nha lực tấn công tâm xa trong đó có tên lửa phạm mình gồm dọn nước này từ phát triển.
Sống thông tin truyền được xanh mình được lập.